this is sort of a vague question Gary
but one of the three steps to get
started in Hollywood in terms of you
remember coming from San Francisco being
in LA I know you have your own story but
I think you got an office and you hired
a secretary and you wait for the phone
to ring look don't do that okay okay
it's a very nice plan but yeah what are
some of the steps in terms of it could
be as an actor a filmmaker screenwriter
but you're just coming to Hollywood from
somewhere else it's total culture shock
you even coming from the Bay Area where
everything seems free and free loves and
wonderful it's so culture shock there's
there's unwritten rules and ya know I
might draw hit the ground when I first
arrived I'm from San Francisco as night
the day this culture and I really didn't
know anybody I didn't know how to
navigate I didn't know the business
actually I had a neighbor who was
brilliantly successful he became the
chairman and CEO of Columbia Pictures
Television he was at the time running
Norman Lear's company very smart very
funny very brilliant guy and he sent me
into meetings at the highest level of
all the major studios and I wore my
heavy wool San Francisco suits in the
middle of a hot summer fit Singh and I
up and I had no idea what these
people were talking about and we made
nice and I left I thought I am an
employable I have no idea and what I did
is I don't really recommend this for
people but I joined it an outdoor health
club and I played tennis all day long
paddle tennis all afternoon tennis in
the morning for hours at a time and
everybody who came on the court they
were all in the entertainment business
and I would take them aside after a game
and say tell me about what you do how do
you do it
what did did job definitions I'd have
questions where really needed the
information and eventually they became
friends and they'd introduced me to
other people in it and it just
snowballed my first six months I made a
hundred friends just by being honest
about where I wanted to go I mean you
have to tell the universe what you want
and I said it repeatedly and I tried to
take people who I thought were some
who were well-mannered who I thought had
some success because if they don't know
who you are at first and you just get
disarmed them you'll find out right you
ask the right questions and you starts
to find out and you use your gut your
heart your your better instrument to say
these people feel real you know I don't
think they're selling me on something
right I don't know the there's no
perfect formula that's gonna work for
everybody it's life it's the life is
very lifelike I mean you know whether
you're an actor is being right or
whatever you are filmmaker someone once
said to me us pretty funny thing and it
was this if you have your laptop and
you've got a few hours to spare and you
want to be productive well you could go
to the local Starbucks and all due
respect to Starbucks you can go to
Starbucks or you could be sitting in the
first-class lounge in LAX in American
Airlines first class lounge at LAX where
do you want to be meeting people so if
you want to meet people who can help you
and it's all about relationship it's all
about making people you know the old
adage is it's who you know and that's
marginally true but underneath that is
the truth which is who feels that they
really know you and not only know you
but like you and trust you
and that's for a port building where are
you gonna find the people that you want
to invest in so that they come to know
like and trust you and will actually
open doors and be helpful for the right
reasons and so I would say you know
there are charities there's events
there's organizations there's places
where people who have been successful
congregate and you have to research that
and it's gonna be different maybe for an
actor than a writer and if you're a
writer you can call the writers guild
say what kind of mixers do you have what
events do you have and you're gonna go
on chat rooms and you're gonna find
people who are really successful online
and you're gonna follow them on Twitter
and it's the same thing you're going to
retweet them you're
to acknowledge them you're going to ask
them a question and after a few months
they're gonna know your handle you're
gonna be familiar and eventually you can
you know there's so many different
strategies online offline but again it's
been intentionality the thing that is
the dividing line and I'm sorry to give
you such a long answer the dividing line
is this some people are just perceiving
life as random and mysterious in it and
and hoping a good thing comes along and
others are saying no I'm gonna go to the
first-class lounge and I'm gonna go to
service on twitter.com and find the top
players and I'm gonna research them on
Google and I'm going to learn where
they're from I'm gonna learn so much
information that they're gonna think I
was their neighbor growing up that's
cool to me it's about gamifying the
business people are a little intimidated
by a turn it into a game make it fun be
honest about it but don't be intimidated
about cold calling just say how can I
make this really interesting for the
other person how can I add value for the
other person and just because you're not
a produced writer or or actor or
whatever it might be never make the
mistake of believing that you don't have
value to contribute to that other person
it may be you find out that they have a
child who is engaged in something you
know something about it maybe they
you're involved with the same charity
they care about it could be a lot of
stuff but there's always emotional
currency and value to be given as a gift
if you care enough
you